diese bilder sorgen gerade in sachsen
für ordentlich aufregung eine gruppe
junger mädchen marschiert im
gleichschritt und in uniform durch
wählen bis nach raten auf ihrer uniform
sind abzeichen zu sehen ein germanisches
creek symbol
doch wer sind diese mädchen darüber
möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit michael
deutschmann er ist jetzt live
zugeschaltet guten abend michael guten
haben was kann es uns auch über dieser
gruppe sagen na ja nicht allzu viel man
muss es zwei teilen es gibt zwei gruppen
die hier aufgetaucht sind die eine die
wir gerade in den sechs bildern gesehen
haben gehört zum sogenannten frei bund
das ist eine jugendorganisation deren
wurzeln bis in die 50er jahre
zurückgehen
damals hieß sie noch heimattreue jugend
das ganze hat sich über die jahre bis in
die siebziger hin und her entwickelt da
gab es zwei flügel einen
rechtsnationalen rechtsextremen flügel
eine eher bündischen flügel der sich in
die jugendbewegung um 1913 zurück
verortet zumindest von seinen wurzeln in
den 90er jahren kam es dann zur spaltung
da hat sich dann die berüchtigte
heimattreue deutsche jugend abgespaltet
das ist dieser verein in dem unter
anderem der fdp-politiker kallwitz
unterwegs gewesen sein soll und der
selbst bei der afg auf der no go liste
steht und es gibt eben diesen bündischen
flügel der seit 2005 allem
rechtsextremismus offiziell abgeschworen
hat und er ja so ein bisschen
wandervogel mäßig tut so ein bisschen
heimat dünkel ein bisschen natur ein
bisschen freigeist und die sind hier
dresden aufgetaucht und haben
volkslieder gesungen auf dem neumarkt so
weit so gut
schwieriger wird es bei der anderen
gruppe die ist zeitgleich aufgetaucht
interessanterweise im in der sächsischen
schweiz wurde unterhalb der bastei
gesehen auf der bastei in königstein und
auch im bibelgarten in raten über die
weiß man tatsächlich relativ wenig nur
dass sie gemeinsame symbole trugen
diesen sogenannten wotans knoten das ist
ein eine germanische runen
sie hat ein gleiche kleidung an die
frappierend an den bund deutscher mädel
aus der ns zeit erinnerte ansonsten sind
sie relativ unauffällig da lang gelaufen
ich war gestern den ganzen tag da
unterwegs und habe versucht mit allen
möglichen passanten kellnern eines cafés
zu sprechen wo die vorbeigekommen sind
die sind nicht aufgefallen die haben
sich nicht daneben benommen aber sie
waren zerstörend in ihrem in ihrem
komischen aufzug in dem komischen look
dankeschön michael deutschland für deine
einordnung